I'm glad to have you on and I know
yesterday we got into so we talked about
this in the first segment the podcast
you wrote a very nice note on Instagram
which was entirely unnecessary III don't
want to say apologizing because you
shouldn't apologize but I hope people
see that we can have a disagreement and
not hate each other I think that's
actually productive yeah I think so too
and what I said to you before we started
was that there's what I always try to do
with the podcast is try to have a
conversation like - it's just hanging
out and that's one of it what I tried to
do at the beginning and I felt like you
kind of had talking points that you
wanted to go over and I wanted to make
it more conversational sign suggest we
start drinking which is fine for a
little while one would say you almost
pressured me I would say that - then it
got to the marijuana subject and things
got a little heated and you know I make
the mistake of often times communicating
like I would with my friends when what I
think is just a joking but aggressive
way yeah and I didn't I didn't
anticipate your reaction to it and you
got defensive and one thing I didn't
take into consideration that I wrote in
the Instagram thing is that you get
attacked a lot this is you you get
attacked a lot in a kind of a scary way
and I think you've done some really bold
things and some really really courageous
things like the whole Mohammed thing I
mean that you didn't have to do that and
you did it and it's a really dangerous
thing and yeah you get attacked so much
that you're always kind of thinking that
someone's setting you up and I didn't
want you to think that I was setting you
up but I had no intention whatsoever
when you came on to set you up I
genuinely like you I think you're a good
guy and I like talking to you and I'd
like to talk to you off air and I was
trying to kind of recreate off air on
air and it didn't seem like it was
happening in the beginning of the
podcast and so that's why I suggested
well no I appreciated looking back kind
of on yesterday because if you look at
kind of obviously the backlash I think
for both of us involved what do you
think and I'll say what do you think we
should have done differently to be more
productive
I guess definitely shouldn't have gotten
drunk for me that wasn't drunk you
weren't drunk
I really wasn't drunk no I had done beer
okay
little whiskey too right that stuff was
awful gentlemen Jack we'll get you some
real bourbon I kind of like the fact
that it's awful that was not but also I
think I need to get to know you better
like where you don't and we both don't
get weird over conversations like that
well we can't just look at facts and
pull things up and I didn't want Jamie I
didn't want you to think that Jamie was
ganging up on you and that's what yeah
where things went bad is that when you
were stating something about the highway
fatalities and it was contrary to what I
thought yeah the kids and then we pulled
up the fact I didn't want you to think
that we were ganging up on you I just
wanted to find out it was I wrong were
you right
what were you wrong was that what what
want to revisit it not to read it but
can I bring up something I didn't have
time to yesterday so and this is
something I think is important because
respectfully Jamie's not experienced in
sourcing articles or looking up news and
to the same degree that that we are so
the very thing he brought up I remember
and here's because I've talked about
this earlier my mental monologue I
thought oh no I've screwed up here and
that's I said you know what Jo I think
you're probably right I'll give it to
you and the reason why was because Jamie
brought up factcheck.org that was the
main source he brought up Washington
Post well he brought in it was
originally from the fact-check org was
the source they were talking about so
there a couple of you brought up but I
remember when he brought up with that
checked org I saw it and I thought oh
crap because I've read that and we've
written about that never thinking you
know what I must have read that wrong
because that's actually an article we've
sourced and I must have meant the
opposite because right below what he
highlighted it actually did say Gary
Johnson was wrong increases in the
incidences were significant marijuana
related traffic deaths increased by a
hundred and fifty-four percent between
oh six - oh fourteen this was in his
source that he brought up so my point is
I can't read it right and this is why I
get defensive I can't read it because
this TV is not working I can't know what
Jamie's bringing up I'm going on memory
he has a never ending cheat sheet and
there's no way that I can can argue with
that and I would say you're right about
this I'm incorrect when I get defensive
it was one two people are saying admit
that you're lying that it's both and I
really looking at his own sources I
don't think I was well I don't think we
were saying you were lying what I think
we're saying you
incorrect and I have read multiple
things that said that the traffic
fatalities decrease particularly in
Colorado right who's right or who's
wrong I don't know I mean we'd have to
go
seriously digging right but his own
source said that's wrong it's my point
not in real time I can't fact check them
because I don't have a computer right
right and he brought up also that that
could also be attributed to the fact
that the population of Denver Colorado
increased substantially once marijuana
became legal as well yeah factor that in
right I think I think when you're
talking about driving impaired I do not
think that marijuana has the same effect
as alcohol it certainly doesn't however
I don't think it's a good idea to drive
up whether you're on marijuana
especially on edibles
I mean edibles hahaha second that wasn't
even a part of the equation I think I'd
really would advise against that yeah
absolutely I think we both dug in our
heels and we agreed probably on a lot
more than we disagreed I think you're
right I think we definitely both dug in
our heels and like I said there's a lot
involved in that first of all I got a
hangover from this guy pipe that you
left me really oh I'm gonna send you an
article on how to use it properly oh
yeah back oh I was high as a kite from
it for sure from the tobacco yes yeah
before I even started drinking my my
head was spinning cuz I I definitely was
inhaling a bunch of times we shouldn't
do that I said because you can actually
get little flecks of tobacco in your
lungs that's not filtered yeah I just
got here from a yoga class I took a
90-minute yoga class I might have copped
some of that up in there yes you might
cough it up I might have some little
flakes of tobacco might have come out is
Joe behaving like the girl from The
Exorcist yeah and I would say this I
will say in my mind too so I thought
well did I screw up and I looked back
now and we talked about it early in the
show
III don't think I did I don't back down
the statements that I've made as far as
my position I don't think that you're
wrong my point is if you look at the
articles and how we sourced it I knew we
weren't bullshitting and I know because
like I said the left is always going
they're foolish but this is a lie
I know how on second this one up we had
a triple-a study the fact-check study
there's a difference between bolting and
having a difference of opinion looking
at interpreting data and and I wanted to
make that
because I still I will still say the
jury can be out and you you may be right
but it was certainly I think a study
worthy of note and then on my side what
I would change is because I know your
Jill Rogen obviously I mean alpha brain
alpha male I've seen you run roughshod
over people who are like well okay Joe
and they get scared and I didn't want to
be that guy because I knew you wouldn't
respect that guy who just goes okay
maybe you would well I mean I didn't
want you to be defensive is that if
that's what you mean I didn't expect you
to dig your heels in I didn't expect you
to be submissive either I just want to
have a conversation yeah just go just
didn't go well part of it that didn't go
well which is fascinating because we had
a father podcast I mean it was a [ __ ]
long podcast yeah and out of that
podcast what was it like 20 minutes of
it we talked about pot and that's all
anybody is focusing on which is but
that's well that's good that's what
Jaime uploaded as a highlight too no he
didn't only somebody uploaded as a
highlight maybe somebody else did I
don't know no I think somebody else did
but either way the the conversations
that we had before that were very simple
yeah and then we ended very civil too
but I think people have this tendency to
gravitate towards conflict they enjoy it
it's like have you ever gone to I'm sure
you have you go to a fighter's page
after a UFC bout and you read all the
talk yeah that people say to them I mean
it's horrendous
I mean my favorite page is mark months
after his fights or something happens
you just read it he's just like can
steroids make everything it just goes in
and just hang me out to dry
do you see Brooke Lesnar you're sitting
you're like it's mark just tone it back
this is gonna be miserable that was mark
I was talking about fans young fans like
like after like Ronda Rousey recently
lost I went and checked like some ver
either like the online things yeah the
things that people were saying about our
means people love can't they love
jumping in and something that really
doesn't they're not really connected to
it but they connect themselves to it
they love conflict where essentially
nothing is at stake for them yeah they
can really get whatever rocks off they
have and thank you so much for being
here sir we appreciate it I'm glad
hopefully people see us it doesn't think
okay well missing maybe they don't hate
each other I don't dude I don't hate you
at all I think you're a good guy
and that's why I made that Instagram
post I saw this back and forth both way
people mad at you people mad at me it
was just so stupid and it was just uh
you know a drunken hiccup in a long
conversation hey if you like this video
subscribe by clicking the button that
says subscribe if you're not aware of it
now there's no way you're learning the
internet at this point I'm not going to
help you but this was clipped from my
daily show available exclusively to
lotto with credit com / mug club members
of your student military or veteran
internet promo code it's less than six
dollars a month and you get daily
content no more clips Plus this hand
etched mug oh I just when I feel it I
got a chill like on the inside